what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us trying to get our lunch
money right i'm here pelina's here we're
ready to rock
and roll don't forget that block five
style sponsor of
lunch money you can go and open a block
by account i'm an investor i sit on the
board i like it you'll like it too
if you go to block five dot com slash
pomp you can deposit crypto and earn up
to eight point six percent apy in an
interest bearing account
where else you're going to earn 8.6
percent apy
in that engineering account you ain't go
check it out
there's risk but that's the game let's
get it
rolling blacklight.com what's up
you know what is rolling rolling up the
hill
bitcoin searched about 52 000
on wednesday for the first time ever
what do we think
is this important do we care or not
at this point i mean it went from 10
to 20 to 30 to 40 to 50. guess what
it's gonna go to 60 to 70 to 80 to 90
to 100 as i've been saying
for two years now or whatever in 2019 i
think i wrote it
bitcoin is going to hit 100 000
by the end of 2021 in my opinion maybe
i'm wrong
i actually think i might be overly
conservative if he's wrong he will write
about it
i'll write about i'll be the first one
to say i'm wrong i don't think i'm gonna
be wrong but we're gonna find out we're
gonna see
we're over halfway there now we're only
two months into the month um
hey baby what up um i like that people
try to speculate what i think about
bitcoin and how i feel about bitcoin
if you don't know by now you ain't gonna
find out
next all right u.s
retail sorry retail sales burst higher
in january as consumers use stimulus
checks
to spend heavily retail sales jumped 5.3
percent to start 2020.
one i think that was just me shopping at
lululemon to be honest
um customers flocked to spend their
stimulus checks in january so is it
working the stimulus stuff
we're consuming we're a consumerist
society
look auto sales rose 5.9
i don't think anyone's using their 500
600 check to buy a car
some people are okay so the five people
who did that what about the
other 330 million americans they're
using their money to
buy things obviously again i think that
this is a little bit of a stretch
yes consumer prices went up i'm willing
to bet that the consumer uh sales went
up
not because of the stimulus check but
because people got let out of their
homes
they literally went into the stores they
ordered online they went and they did
things like they're trying to live their
lives
the stimulus sure it just wasn't that
big of a check
this is interesting electronics and
appliances saw the biggest increase
up point seven percent for the month
well furniture and home furnishings
stores were up twelve percent in online
spending and non-store retail
tailors jumped to eleven percent so
people need their cameras they need
their zoom
well i think like the furniture and home
furnishings stores up 12 percent like
people are moving they're literally like
saying hey
i got to go places there are a lot of uh
leases that roll off at the end of
december like all this kind of stuff
yes i'm sure stimulus has some impact
but you can't just say oh
we gave everyone 5 600 bucks and they
went they bought cars like that's
ridiculous
okay let's go all right elon musk says
spacex is
raised 850 million dollars jumping
valuation to about 74
billion it keeps raising money people
wow it costs 419.99 a share
yeah spacex is probably going to end up
being one of the most valuable companies
in the world
obviously monster that's pretty dope who
do they raise from or is this in the
public
where did they yeah who do they race
from
uh i don't think that they announced who
they actually raised money from look
spacex is a fantastic business
if i remember the numbers correctly that
i've read i think they get paid like a
billion billion dollars for every rocket
launch
and they've got pretty good like healthy
unit economics on it
so like you can imagine a business where
if you launch it 30 times
in a year you get 30 billion dollars
like that's pretty good business
um and then they've got star uh link
which is the
um kind of network of satellites around
the world that are going to be in the
internet there's no wi-fi to people
i have over 10 000 subscribers on that
like this is going to be a pretty pretty
big company so i'm
excited to uh to kind of see what
happens with that one
all right elizabeth elizabeth holmes of
thera knows
her attorneys are strongly pushing back
against the government's attempt to
detail her extravagant lifestyle before
a jury
saying the move risks invoking class
prejudice
that is that is irrelevant to her
criminal case
she is facing a dozen criminal wire
fraud charges
and she earned a salary and benefits
commissure with her position
as ceo of their nose her attorneys wrote
in court
i'm torn on this one i so here's here's
what you think here's my take
yeah the government has argued and i
think this is the biggest argument
anybody has that her lifestyle was
fueled by the fraud
of the company so that's why i'm torn
which is
i gener i generally believe the
government
shouldn't have a say in how you live who
cares
like you know all this kind of stuff you
want to go light your money on fire and
knock yourself out you want to do
something crazy like next yourself
how did you but that's the key so if
she was basically defrauding people to
get the money to then live her lifestyle
then it's important to understand
what were you doing like all this kind
of stuff her attorneys say that's simply
not true so we will find out what
happens in court so that's the key piece
is if there was defrauding to get money
and they use the money to go do all this
crazy stuff like okay that's one thing
but if
you didn't defraud people for the money
that you used to go do something that's
why did you get the money to do stuff
well i mean who knows maybe she had uh
some other big business maybe she
inherited money like maybe
you know somebody gave it to her like i
i just don't know and so in these
situations i'm always very very cautious
because it's so complex and when you get
lawyers all yelling at each other
it usually something else is going on so
let's just wait and
uh then we'll about my dad who is a
chemical engineer is like
i don't like lawyers because scientists
we try to make
things obvious and and lawyers they try
to take the facts and make it like
not obvious
i just fought that yawn off i just
punched that yawn right in the face i'm
like now you ain't gonna get me i know i
got you though i saw it
all right let's go let's go another
thing that i'm right about
let's go hit me with it so my close
personal friend
dwayne the rock johnson is not
ruling out a potential presidential bid
he said if that's
what the people let me find the original
quote he said i would consider a
presidential run in the future if that's
what the people wanted
truly i mean that and i'm not flippant
in any way with my answer
that would be up to the people so i
would wait and i would listen
i would have my finger on the pulse my
ear to the ground let's go rock
let's go i've been telling y'all i've
been telling y'all
the rock is gonna be the president i've
been saying this for years
all don't listen to me but i'm telling
you the rock is gonna be the tell us
your reasoning
one he's the most recognizable person in
the world
hands down point blank done he's
charismatic
he's humorous he's actually very
intelligent
he's very very collaborative in the way
that he works with people
and he's six for 280 pounds and he will
whoop your ass
if you get out of line no the reason one
of the biggest uh um
kind of things that point to who's going
to be the president is when they all
stand on stage in a debate
whoever's the most physically uh most
bearing right like meaning like
if you're the tallest or you're the
biggest the strongest it's just human
nature
oh that's the leader and so the like
there's nobody bigger than the rock
and then on top of that like imagine if
he was in a debate uh in a presidential
debate
and uh the other candidate said
something crazy like whether it was an
extreme on either end
extreme left or extreme right never see
all kinds of crazy stuff and the rock
just hit him with
shut your candy ass up everyone would go
wild
like they would go nuts like the rock is
the man but now are we just turning our
presidential elections into popularity
contests
it's been a popularity contest forever
they've been pretending like they're
some elitist intellectuals that are
gonna actually look out for us
the government ain't coming to do
nothing for you there's no one coming to
see you you are responsible for you
so guess what if we know that then let's
get a somebody who's cool somebody who
can kick ass
hey vladimir putin you think that you're
cool riding around on a horse with no
shirt on we got the
rock as the president the rock is
holding his little daughter's hand
walking down the street i just love him
while in his other hand he's crushing
the globe
the rock ain't playing around what up
you want to come
talk that [ __ ] now come talk that [ __ ]
we got the rock would you vote for the
rock
i gotta listen to his policies first
wait but i'm just talking about
can we get a g7 or g12 meeting going and
the rock walks in there goes where the
candy ass is at
hold on i will post this below in the
comments watch out for my comment
um i will i recently did a profile
dossier on the rock and the rock liked
it and the rock retweeted it like four
times and put it on his instagram
so he liked it you will like it i will
like you for liking it
there we go also the rock said i'd like
to see greater leadership when there's a
disagreement and you have a large group
of people that you're in disagreement
with for example the media
i feel like it informs me that i could
do better we all have issues and we
gotta
all work out work our [ __ ] out and i
feel like one of the qualities of a
great leader is not shutting people out
i miss that part
the rock's showing up and he's like boom
boom
i got two guns
okay you are not the rock let's put this
i'm not
i'm not but i'm just saying can you
imagine the rock showing up and
insane things what no like
boom boom i got two deadly weapons
go ahead i wish you ran for president as
the rock to be honest
um okay so now we have
asked lunch money time hashtag ask lm in
the comments well we have three minutes
based on my clock not the clock on lunch
money so
let's roll moist so what are we gonna do
about moist we didn't moist moist moist
we didn't post lunch money yesterday
he's like like now
his 90 days are getting nah moist you
get credit for yesterday
i messed up yesterday i ran out of time
i couldn't post it
so i'm gonna this is how it is working
with me you see i'm gonna give you free
credit on that one you
yesterday counts okay we got one moist
counter
[Music]
we got one question for us on twenty
today from caleb brown
what's one thing you know about mayor
suarez that's the mayor of miami
that not many people know about oh i
know one go
he's got a basketball hoop in his office
and he has real like little basketballs
you can play with
i'm gonna do a more serious one that
dude works his
butt off he does though like sure people
see him on twitter they see all this
stuff they're like oh this dude is just
trying to
a lot yeah like he works
um and the one thing that i appreciate
about people
is if you work you can make progress you
can actually build things you can do
stuff and
um literally i'll give you an example uh
he went to the city commissioner meeting
uh when they got all of the bitcoin
stuff approved and that was very
difficult for them to do but he got it
done
and so kudos to him for getting that
done um and
it ended very late at night the next
morning
he went to washington dc to meet with
president biden along with a number of
other mayors and kind of local leaders
and so when you look at that type of
lifestyle
where it's 24 7 365 you're responsible
for the success or failure
of a population that ain't the life many
people want
right that's not a that's not a life
that this is very easy
yeah but the rock gonna be like bam i
got all these deadly weapons
can you i mean listen i like i like
mayor suarez
i like him a lot but the rock would put
his head right in between his bicep and
forearms and then just crush him
no he would not look suarez he's
probably a pretty buff guy probably goes
to the gym works out a lot but the rock
the rock the rock would take john clark
van damme and throw him through the wall
with a flick of his finger what is
jean-claude van damme up to easter being
old and soft i can guarantee it
all right that's it for lunch money
today i don't know where jean-claude van
damme came from
but jackie chan john claude van damme
and they were the man back when i was
growing up but the rock
the rock hey man if you need some help
in the presidential campaign call
paulina you already know she could write
well see ya
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fire
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends